the table gives selected values of the
continuous function f alright fair
enough
can we use the intermediate value
theorem to say that the equation f of X
is equal to zero has a solution where 4
is less than or equal to X is less than
or equal to 6 if so write a
justification so pause this video and
see if you can think about this on your
own before we do it together
okay well let's just visualize what's
going on and visually think about the
intermediate value theorem so if that's
my y-axis there and then let's say that
this is my x-axis right over here we've
been given some points over here we know
when X is equal to 0 f of X is equal to
0 let me draw those so I mean we have
that point when X is equal to 2y or f of
X y equals f of X is going to be equal
to negative 2 so we have a negative 2
right over there when X is equal to 4 so
3 for f of X is equal to 3 1 2 3 I'm
doing on a slightly different scale so
that I can show everything and when X is
equal to 6 so 5 6 f of X is equal to 7
so 3 4 5 6 7 so right over here now they
also tell us that our function is
continuous so what intuitive way of
thinking about continuity is I can
connect all of these dots without
lifting my pencil so the function might
look I'm just gonna make up some stuff
it might look something anything like
what I just drew just now and it could
have even Wilder fluctuations but that
is what my F looks like now the
intermediate value theorem says hey pick
a closed interval and here we're picking
the closed interval from 4 to 6 so let
me look at that so this is 1 2 3 4 here
this is 6 here so we're gonna look at
this closed interval and the
intermediate value theorem tells us that
look if we're continuous over that
closed interval our function f is going
to take on every value between F of 4 f
of 4 which in this case so this is f of
4 is equal to 3 and f of 6 and f of 6
which is equal to 7
f of six which is equal to seven and so
if someone said hey is there going to be
a solution to f of X is equal to say
five over this interval yes over this
interval for some X you're going to have
f of X being equal to five but they're
not asking us for an f of X equaling
something between these two values
they're asking us for an f of X equaling
zero zero isn't between F of 4 and F of
6 and so we cannot use the intermediate
value theorem here and so if we wanted
to write it out we could say f is
continuous is continuous but but zero is
not between between F of 4 and F of 6 so
the intermediate value theorem does not
apply alright let's do the second one so
here they say can we use the
intermediate value theorem to say that
there is a value C such that f of C
equals zero and 2 is less than or equal
to C is less than or equal to 4 if so
write that write a justification so we
are given that f is continuous so let me
write that down we are given that f is
continuous and if you want to be over
that interval but they're telling us
it's continuous in general and then we
can just look at what is the value of
the function at these endpoints so our
interval goes from 2 to 4 so we're
talking about this closed interval right
over here we know that F of 2 f of 2 is
going to be equal to negative 2 we see
it in that table and what's F of 4 f of
4 is equal to 3 f of 4 is equal to 3 so
0 is between is between F of 2 and F of
4 and you can see it visually here
there's no way to draw between this
point and that point and without picking
up your pen
without crossing the x-axis without
having a point where your function is
equal to zero and so we can say so
according according to the intermediate
value theorem there is a value C such
that F of C is equal to zero and 2 is
less than or equal to C is less than or
equal to 4 so all we're saying is hey
there must be a value C and the way I
drew it here that Vout that C value is
right over here where C is between 2 & 4
where f of C is equal to zero and this
seems all mathy and and a little bit
confusing sometimes but it's saying
something very intuitive if I had to go
from this point to that point without
picking up my pen I am going to at least
cross every value between F of 2 and F
of 4 at least once